last summer i was hiking through the
austrian mountains
and there on top
i saw this beautiful stone remote hut
and it had solar panels on it
and every time i see solar panels i get
very enthusiastic
this is technology that takes sunlight
which is free and available and turns
that into electricity
so this hut in the middle of nowhere on
a beautiful location
was self-sufficient
but why do solar panels always have to
be so ugly
my name is mariano van alvo and i'm a
solar designer
i work in the trying of design
sustainability and technology
i strive for extreme efficiency
meaning i develop materials that expands
in size or work with solar cells that
use the properties of colors to generate
electricity
my work is in museums all over the world
such as moma
and i mean it ovens quite well
but it always felt that something was
missing
and it was until i read the book called
the solar revolution
where it says that within one hour we
receive enough sunlight to provide the
world with enough electricity for an
entire year
one hour
and since then i realized i just want to
focus on solar
scientists all over the world have been
focusing on making solar phenols more
efficient and cheaper
so the price of soil has dropped
enormously and this is because china
started developing
producing them on a large scale
and also their efficiency has increased
a lot they now even have an efficiency
of 44 and a half percent
but if we think about the image of solar
cells
it's kind like stay the same for the
last 60 years
it still is technology just tagged onto
something
and solar cells need to be much better
integrated into our environment
climate change is the biggest problem of
our time
and we can't rely on the others the
government engineers to make positive
changes we all can contribute towards
change
like i say i'm a designer and i would
like to change things through
design let me give you some examples of
my work
i'm collaborating with swarovski the
crystal company
and if you cut crystals in a certain way
you're able to bend and direct the light
onto a certain place
so i use these crystals to focus the
light onto a solar panel
making them more efficient by using
aesthetics
so you take the solar crystal with you
in the light there's a battery in the
solar cell
you put it in a docking station and
you're able to power these chandeliers
so you're literally bringing the lights
indoors
i got completely hooked on solo when i
came across this technology called dye
sensitized solar cells
colored solar cells and they are based
on photosynthesis in plants
where the green chlorophyll converts
light into sugar for plants these cells
convert light into electricity
the best thing is they even work indoors
so different colors have different
efficiency depending on their place in
the color spectrum so for example
red is more efficient than blue
so if i hear this as a designer a
colored surface a glass colored surface
color that's mostly just used for
aesthetics
now gets an extra function and is able
to harvest electricity
i think
where can we apply this then this is
current table where the whole table top
consists out of these colored solar
cells
the batteries in the legs where you can
charge your phone from through through
usb ports
and in my work it's always very
important the balance between efficiency
and aesthetics so that's why the table
is orange because it's a very stable
color for indoors
and it's always the most asked question
i get is okay great but how many phones
can i charge from this then
and before i go to this complicated
answer of like well where is the table
does it have enough light is it next to
a window
the table has now sensors that read the
light intensity of the room so through
an app we developed you can literally
follow how much light is getting and how
full the battery is
i'm actually quite proud because
yesterday we installed the table at
stifting dunes offices here in amsterdam
and right at this moment our queen
maxima is charting the phone from this
table
that's cool
thank you
so the more surface you have the more
energy you can harvest these are current
windows where we replaced all windows in
a gallery in london in soho
with car with this modern version of
stained glass
so people from the streets could come
and charge your phones through the
window ledges
so i'm giving extra functions to objects
a window doesn't have to be just a
window anymore but can also function as
a little power station
so
here i am talking about how i'm much i
love solar
that i don't have solar panels on my
roof
i live in the center of amsterdam i
don't own the house and it's a monument
so it's not possible and that's allowed
so how can we make solar cells more
accessible and for everyone
and not only for the people that can
afford a sustainable lifestyle
we now have the opportunity to integrate
solar on the place where we directly
need it
and there's so many amazing technologies
out there
if i look around now i see every service
as an opportunity
for example i was driving in the train
through the westlands the area in the
netherlands with all the greenhouses
there i saw all this glass and thought
what if we integrate those with
transparent solar clouds
what if we integrate what combined
traditional farming that requires a lot
of energy
together with high-tech and
combine those
with this idea in mind i created power
plants
um
i created like i had a team of
architects and engineers but let me
first explain how it works
we use transparent solar glass
powering its indoor climate
we use hydroponics that pumps around
nutrified water saving 90 percent of
water usage
by stacking up the layers you're able to
grow more yields per square meter
extra light besides sunlight coming from
these colored led lights
also enhances plant growth
as more and more people will live in big
cities by placing power plants onto
rooftops you don't have to fly it in
from the other side of the world we're
able to grow it on the location itself
what the big dream is to build these in
off-grid places when there's no access
to water electricity it's an independent
ecosystem
for this year's design biennial i
created the first four meters heist
model of the power plants so you could
come in and experience how plants grow
it's a double harvest of sunlight so
both for the solar cells and for the for
the plants
it's like a
future botanical
garden where we celebrate all these
modern technologies
and the biggest compliment i got was but
where are the solar panels
and that's when i think design really
works when it becomes invisible when you
don't notice it
i believe in solar democracy
solar energy for everyone everywhere
my aim is to make all surfaces
productive i want to build houses where
all the windows curtains walls even
floors are harvesting electricity
think about this on a big scale in
cities
there's so many surfaces
the sun is still available for everyone
and by integrating solar on a place
where we need it we now have the
opportunity to make solar cell
accessible for everyone
i want to bring
solar closer to the people with you
but
beautiful and well designed
thank you